also leute wir haben hier den kleinsten
stimmen verzehr der welt drittel leute
was glaubt ihr leid was die da jetzt
bekommen zu meinen neuen video jetzt
anzugehen
irgendwie ist das bild gerade extrem
kacke so jetzt erwarte ich sollte mal
wieder das richtige tue was gehabt und
jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen video
[Musik]
leute das geht ab herzlich willkommen zu
einem video war ja das heißt aber anders
egal
ja ich habe euch geht es gut mir auch
ich bin nur ein bisschen fertig mit den
nerven heute anstrengender tag und so
eigentlich das video schon heute morgen
machen ging aber nicht weil meine kamera
weg war an dieser stelle schon grüße
auch an mein mitbewohner danke und zwar
steht heute ein video an dass ich
einfach mal auf mich zukommen lasse weil
ich irgendwie überhaupt keine ahnung hat
wie ich dieses video men soll was ich
genau video mitteilen da anfangen soll
aber die sachen sind echt ganz witzig
und zwar hat marie ich weiß ja wie die
candy hat mir die sachen aus der stadt
gebracht wo gab es die beiden outfitters
wenn ihr den laden nicht kennt seid ihr
nicht alleine ich kann ihnen auch nicht
einmal einen daumen nach oben die
irgendwie das können und im heutigen
video geht es um das sind die kleinsten
produkte was genau
laser gun weil der kann meine stimme
verstellen
erstmal ist okay ihr habt es gehört also
einmal laser stimm verzerrer und walkie
talkies walkie talkies sind die teile
die man früher im kindergarten über
benutzt hat um miteinander zu
kommunizieren haben wir zumindest im
kindergarten gemacht ich weiß nichts bei
euch aussieht so also wir probieren die
sachen einfach mal aus wie schon gesagt
das sind die kleinsten sachen davon
dieses sagt keine angedeutet wir haben
ja einmal diese laser braucht man dafür
batterien
das ganze hat zehn euro kostet warum
gibts sowas in einem klamottenladen so
wir haben ja einmal die farbe blau und
die farbe rot ich will das einfach mal
schätzen das sind laserpointer oder also
praktisch diese dinger womit man gerne
mal den anderen blendet was man aber
nicht machen sollte weil das ist
schlecht für die augen und das lässt
sich jetzt mal kommt der wirklich
strahlt
walter ich bislang jedoch hier oben ist
doch das habe ich gott aufgerufen
das hat nichts mit einem laserpointer zu
tun oder einer laser gun und mache mir
irgendwas falsch da sind ja lichter
lasst uns einmal das ziel dunkel machen
so leute wir haben es jetzt hier
ziemlich dunkel
das sieht aber schon cool aus aber
irgendwie ist es trotzdem so leute
kommen wir zu jeder zeit voll cool aus
gerade also den laserpointer kann man
nicht empfehlen hier kann es wieder
zurück haben dann würde ich gar nicht
gebe mir mal bitte den stimm verzerrer
hat also leute wir haben hier den
kleinsten stimmen verzehr der welt und
jetzt einfach rein sprechen du kannst
dir die stufen verstellen hier gibt es
eins zwei drei und vier
das hört sich an wie so eine metalband
hast du meine hasse meine stimme auch
dabei okay dann muss jetzt mal erraten
was ich sage ja okay dann sag ich noch
was anderes
nein
[Musik]
alex du bist alex sings du ein lied
keine ahnung also ich muss an dieser
stelle
ja nee ich fans ja ganz cool wird das
funktionieren soll es funktioniert ja
echt überhaupt nicht und dann 17 euro
dafür hat das jetzt zwei euro kostet
okay so leute also kompletter müll kann
man eigentlich sofort ein papierkorb
audi natürlich nicht im papierkorb
sondern anderen müll kurzem ein kleiner
schock und zwar checkt auf jeden fall
meinen instagram grad ab weil ich mache
gerade einen tag bestimmt instagram
einen ernährungsplan und das haben erste
steht euch noch an also abdecken und mit
abstimmen gehen wir jetzt kurz die
wolken talkies leute jetzt bin ich mal
wirklich gespannt und zwar wenn das
funktioniert dann ziehe ich den hut weil
ich habe früher so ein fan davon so
einfach mit seinen freunden über walkie
talkies zu kommunizieren ich hatte noch
eine vernünftige kindheit wir waren
oftmals draußen unterwegs haben so ein
spiel gespielt das räuber und gendarm
kennst du das und da haben jetzt immer
mit walkie-talkies kommuniziert und wir
hatten echt gute walkie talkies sie
konnten so über 1 2 kilometer
kommunizieren und hier haben jetzt mocki
für zehn euro alt 10 euro für sein ding
ist voll okay also leute so sind die aus
was denn rausziehen hallo hallo hallo
hallo hallo jemand mein zimmer hat mir
kurz was da rein
hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo ich höre
ich nicht auf
also hier steht das geht bis zu 100g bis
zu 30 meter sich dieser kreis eigentlich
hallo
existiert nicht und da noch irgendwas
falsch hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo was
sie das ist auf jeden fall tag ja dann
vielleicht müssen wir auch thomas
krücken und zuhören drückt du mal darauf
und ich sage hallo hallo
hallo hörst du mich ja heute wegdrücken
hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo was mich
also hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo nicht
mehr gesteht 30 meter trifft ja hallo
hallo hallo hallo was wir tauschen
das ist gehört du musst jetzt gehen
drauf drücken nicht geheilt doch
wirklich ich schwöre dir das kam ein
kleiner rausgehen autos leichter weg
gerückt
beim letzten klappe ich sehr schwer ich
muss mir da ein ich glaube du hast das
nur ausgedacht das dümmste was ich will
doch mal ganz kurz gucken schweiz gehört
haben
warum aber eher das ist doch kompletter
scheiß oder also fährt jetzt wirklich
gedacht die teile funktionieren
das war richtig cool gewesen ja auch das
habe ich auf so beeindruckt ich werde
wieder laden verkauft und normalerweise
klamotten und ich da spiele einzig der
ganzen welt nein ich frage mich so jetzt
mal halt kunden die das nicht für den
finnen youtube-video verwenden möchten
was macht man damit und ja aber das
funktioniert ja nicht leute das war's
mit diesem unfassbar spektakulären video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen morgen
jetzt wieder ein cooles video und zwar
einen tag bestimmen instagram meinen
ernährungsplan das bin ich gerade noch
nebenbei produzieren also das war
eigentlich nur eine sache die mega
spontan war gerade
so leute wir sehen uns immer auf jeden
fall nicht vergessen und yahoo